[Applaudissements]
je vais vous raconter une histoire qui
s'appelle l'école de la vie c'est
l'histoire d'un papa c'est à dire moi
jean-louis avec ses deux garçons jérémy
et benjamin cette histoire démarre au
chu de poitiers le 19 avril 1991 la
naissance de benjamin alors à l'époque
quand on allait en maternité ça durait
une semaine est arrivé au sixième jour
de la maternité donc la veille du départ
les médecins nous annonce que benjamin
est trisomique 21 et l' autre vie elle
bascule est vraiment l d'inscrire vous
êtes faire déchoir faut dire qu est ce
qu on fait tout ça et moi je viens d'une
éducation d'une maman pieds-noirs et
vous savez ce que peut être une maman
baignoire et elle lui dit il est mort
multifils c'est un ange 21
et pourquoi y grandissent avec la
famille et l'histoire a commencé à
partir de ce jour là l'école de la vie
je m'étais dit il faut que benjamin soit
autonome et j'ai 25 ans pour réussir ce
pari
parce que on ne sait bien on n'est pas
éternelle sur terre et deux ans plus
tard jérémy benjamin nous avons dû faire
face à un divorce
jérémy est restée vive axa maman et moi
j'ai eu une balle en main elvis que sa
maman l'abandonner
donc c'était quand même assez
douloureuse qu'en dire il a fallu
avancer et benjamin a vécu deux
expériences qui paraît à la fois de
coeur est à la fois obscures il est
rentré à l'époque il avait trois ans à
la crèche parentale de beaulieu la
pommerie il a passé une superbe année
une excellente année ça a été le bonheur
partagé avec les enfants qui étaient
avec lui il ya un partage ça s'est
tellement bien passé que la maman carew
pour remercier toutes les personnes qui
avaient à coeur pour les dix ans de la
monnerie a fait une paille à pied noir
pour 250 personnes et je peux vous dire
qu'elle était bonne la mer maintenant on
va parler de la deuxième phase est il a
fallu le benjamin grandissent alors je
me suis rapproché du sésame qui
appartient aux papillons blancs de la
vienne et j'ai dit benjamin on va
essayer de l'intégrer dans une
maternelle et il est rentrée en
maternelle sur beaulieu et un jour je
reçois un coup de téléphone et c'était
la nourrice de benjamin qui m'appelait
un bijou oui on a un problème si c'est
quoi le problème hélène mais c'est ton
fils va lancer comme tous les enfants ça
peut à un moment donné mordre il avait
mordu un enfant même beach et il y a
pire et ça c'est le côté obscur une
eu en face de toi
des parents qui ont signé une pétition
pour le virer de matériel et là il faut
face au problème benjamin est rentré
dans la foulée en dit m
à saint benoît les papiers roulant mais
ça j'ai voulu grandir un peu plus
comprendre des choses et je me suis dit
séparant au lieu de demander de voir tu
es professionnel de voir l'éducatrice de
parler de la trisomie 21
je me suis dit c'est peut-être la peur
la peur de saper un enfant trisomique
ans à mort ça peut donner la peste ou le
choléra
alors j'ai pris une autre option pour
pouvoir grandir rester sur du positif
est relancé j'ai décidé de faire le
pardon et la vie est reparti quelques
années plus tard benjamin à l'âge de 13
ans et avec son frère jérémy nous avions
décidé de faire ensemble un autre pari
pour l'éducation de son frère
j'ai appelé un club de rugby dans la
vienne pour ne pas les citer
saint georges les baillargeaux j'ai
appelé mon ami philippe qui était le
président et bertrand qui était
l'entraîneur et je leur ai dit est ce
que voulait bien prendre mon fils
pendant une année au rugby la réponse a
été aussitôt
oui benjamin a passé une superbe année
avec l'école de rugby les gamins il ne
faisait que les entraînements et à jour
fils il vient voir une bille ton fils il
a déjà fait du rugby j'ai tu sais vous
tue c'est fini les enfants de réseau
mais s'il fonctionne par mimétisme
ils regardent la télé pour qu'il regarde
les plaquages il regarde les to soucy
jamais il sait faire nba a beau parce
que tant qu'il plaque les enfants vous
imaginez bien rejoindre un 13 ans
costauds comme ça quand ils plaquent ça
bouge pas
et là c'était une année une année une
année de bonheur avec son frère parce
que son frère comme je vous disais jury
mais était là donc assister aux
entraînements donc c'était vraiment la
famille
quatre ans plus tard benjamin à 17 ans
et c'était ça a été pour moi en tout cas
la partie la plus pénible pour moi
à 23 ans le décès de jérémy
il avait décidé comme dit la chanson de
michel berger de rejoindre son paradis
blanc et pour la première fois pour la
première fois vous aviez un papa qui
mettait les deux genoux à terre mais je
veux dit c'est comment sortir de cette
impasse et j'ai trouvé la solution c'est
la mienne
il a fallu en venir j'ai fait appel à un
personnage qui s'appelle maître yoda
parce que lui dans ce qu'il dit et c'est
né s'est pas tu n'as pas le choix
et comme il disait aux jedi fait appel à
la force
en gros dés jamais mieux servi que par
toi même et je me suis dit force tu
retrouveras courage d'une multipliera
volonté du sénat et victor arthur école
de la vie a continué on gère partis
là-dessus je suis rentré je me suis
impliqué dans le conseil
d'administration des papillons blancs de
la vienne et de l'adapei 4
ainsi ce benjamin à cette époque là il
ya quatre ans était déjà devenue
autonome
ce qu'il était rentré dans un foyer dis
donc aujourd'hui il a sa vie avec son
père puis la vie la sienne puis je vous
donnais halki secret depuis un an lhasa
pitch eric isabelle valérie j'ai voulu
pousser l'histoire justement par rapport
à toutes les étapes j'ai voulu faire
l'histoire un peu plus loin et j'ai créé
en 2015 solidarité handicap 86 c'est une
association qui organise une fois par an
de l'événementiel
le but c'est de récolter des fonds pour
des associations qui s'occupent soit de
maladies soient d'handicap
l'histoire a commencé en 2015 donc à
l'époque j'avais commencé par des sosies
le sosie de sébastien patof le sosie de
véronique sanson
j'avais quelques gipsy et pour la
première fois il était venu de paris que
c'est un ami je faisais connaissance de
bébert des formes en 2016
j'ai fait venir fabienne thibeault du
starmania
fabienne thibeault à une nef trisomiques
21 le graal il a été atteint en avril
j'ai fait venir dans la vienne deux
groupes de la vienne
christophe rasés et les rolling stones
automne et les papas seul club
et en deuxième partie
c'étaient les 40 en déformant sur scène
le groupe entier hélas ce projet là
honnêtement vous cache pas
pour une fois je pensais avoir c'était
mon projet le mien et je faisais ce que
je voulais et je me suffis pouvez même
pas savoir plaisir et j'ai fait un autre
pari j'avais mon petit ego à moi et je
suis dit ton fils benjamin va danser
devant les forbans parce que derrière
tout ça ça a été un an d'entraînement
pour arriver à danser de en informant
vous avez une scène les forbans sont là
et devant les forbans vous avez des
fauteuils roulants
vous avez des autistes vous avez des
trisomiques
vous avez des personnes des six
lancements talent et vous avez le public
r c'était le vivre ensemble
c'était un moment de fête deux fois de
bonheur de partage et c'était vraiment
vraiment bien ce que je vais vous
demander cher public et ainsi que tous
les autres publics c'est de vous lever
si vous voulez bien de vous tenir la
main
de fermer les yeux et de bien écouter
sacro que je vais vous dire partage
solidarité amour bonté bienveillance et
pour vous remercier d'avoir pris le
temps de de m'écouter
j'ai quelqu'un qui vous voulez vous
faire plaisir qui m'a dit qu'il me l'a
demandé je vais faire lire sur scène mon
fils benjamin
vous savez que c'est un danseur de rock
and roll je voulais dit tout à l'heure
donc justement il veut il veut faire
partie de la fête avait pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hibou
ans
[Musique]
et on finit à la clé pour finir tout le
public ici présents ainsi que tous vos
proches avec benjamin jérémy de là-haut
et moi même vous souhaitons à toutes et
tous bonheur santé et prospérité et
amour et on vous aide
merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]